well adam vinatieri tracking down
herschel walker with marv albert on the
that's crazy
i never understood the shoulder pads
herschel walker wore well i had
forgotten about those my god how do you
have any flexibility how do you have any
moves how do you how do you it just he
looked so uncomfortable in those
shoulder pads didn't he yeah i in that
whole era i mean think about that whole
er everybody's wearing these like
gigantic shoulder pads and doing that
you know it was just a little bit more
protection now the shoulder pads have
become so much more technologically
superior it's amazing what they are now
as compared to even when i was
in high school or my early years of
college football now they're
just as strong or stronger with being
you know a third of the size a quarter
of the size a quarter of the weight
which allows the players to be even
faster and throw their bodies around
more aggressively and all those things
and those are the reasons why you hear
about the game being more violent now
maybe than then but yeah those things
are gigantic and
wait i it it it's actually it just
reminds you how old adam venetieri is
the fact that he was playing against
herschel walker i was like what wait
what are we showing here i couldn't
quite figure it out at first
and finitary actually played for the
colts longer than he played for the
patriots i always think of him though as
a patriot because he had the huge kicks
with new england each of the three field
goals they won during his time there
they won by three points and obviously
the snow globe game with the tuck rule
he made the 45-yard line drive to tie it
up and force overtime and then made the
game winner in overtime rick cordella
who is one of the executives at peacock
and used to be in charge of
nbcsports.com sent me last night
a photo of the the image on the screen
as vina terry was getting ready to kick
that field goal and it said at the
bottom has missed four of his last five
field goal attempts that's amazing you
can't there it is there it is you can't
help but wonder if he misses this kick
what it does to his career right because
then it's five of six and the patriots
season's over do they find a new kicker
for 2002. yeah that's a very good
question but you know it's it's it's
again it's the story of so many great
players where it was like oh there's
this this one tipping point that
launched him into greatness but i think
that is part of his greatness right
there though
like
just his ability to handle pressure
regardless oh i've missed these field
goals this one's to win it and go to the
afc championship game you know even
remember the super bowl against the
carolina panthers and that's super bowl
i believe he had like two missed field
goals early on in the game but late in
the game oh it's a 41-yard attempt 29-29
i mean there was no doubt i was sitting
in the stands this day i was just going
there there's no doubt it's going right
through and the patriots are world
champion so you just you never doubted
it in these moments and really until
like two years ago
i don't i can't even remember
like
adam benatari coming off the field
disappointed he missed a big field goal
i feel like it never happened to the guy
yeah and in 2019 he did struggle and i
remember there was a a question were
they even going to cut him loose was he
retired during the season
he's he's a
an important leader in the locker room
because he's transcended that position
because he's meant so much to so many
teams and he didn't play in 2020 and
there was a story yesterday i think that
he had he had maybe kicked around the
idea of coming back no pun intended at
all because it would have been a
horrible one and then he told pat mcafee
yesterday that uh he's retiring and i
this is the first
kicker or punter that i can recall who
from the moment of retirement it's a
no-brainer he's getting in the hall of
fame yeah i think i don't know that he
gets in in five years or four years now
since he didn't play in 2020 but it's a
no-brainer the guys getting in
no-brainer i mean
yeah it goes in as you know one of the
greatest kickers of all time the most
clutch kicker of all time and i feel
like this is the
only kicker punter
i can remember that
has retired or made an announcement like
this and it's kind of treated like he's
a real nfl star football player i don't
mean that to be silly or disrespectful
but like you're right right right like
it's a real like it's a linebacker or a
pass rusher or a quarterback i mean
that's where he's different he's been
such a part of our our history and
football here for so long really awesome
career to him and congrats on the
retirement
yeah you've got
bill belichick issuing his statement
robert kraft issuing a statement i mean
yeah this is a guy who
up
was just different than the other
kickers and uh and will end up in canton
and maybe he'll get there on the first
bat
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports